sam amick USA Today NBA insider the man
who mispronounces his own last name kind
enough to join us again Sam good morning
how are you well thank you my friend
that's a one of a kind of introduction I
appreciate it I'm gonna get you to
change it back to a man I am I'm gonna
get you you just go with one one name
you're a soccer player or musician
you're Samak you say yeah yeah you're
saying that was an old college nickname
so that's okay we can do Saavik you have
my green light on that dance all right
so Sam ik is joining us here I where do
you want to start I mean light let's
start with what reality is right now
with building a super team in Los
Angeles what is the reality of that it
seems murky you know doesn't mean it's
not gonna happen but I thought by this
point leading up to July 1 then we would
add more clarity that we do in terms of
some of these chess pieces and whether
it might be landing
we don't have clarity you know I had
written something the other day about
college origin listen pretty agencies
crazies nothing has changed I mean going
into it a lot of optimism on the
Oklahoma City side that he could be
returning I think more interestingly is
pessimism problems and LeBron James camp
that he might be headed to LA and that
was obviously a guy that we've been
talking about for a long time to join
LeBron the Kawhi Leonard stuff is messy
the Spurs seem to have no interest
whatsoever in cooperating with the
Lakers let alone training him at all we
don't know what's gonna happen there you
know then Chris Paul a lot of signs
pointing to him and most every sign
pointing to him staying in Houston so
I'm just not sure who LeBron is gonna
get help from that he's coming
could you see LeBron going to Los
Angeles without Kawhi Leonard and/or
Paul George says yeah I mean you know
I'm actually I enjoy free agency every
year but this one in particular I'm kind
of dying to know exactly what LeBron is
thinking in that scenario I've pondered
recently and I think I could see it I'm
the you know the idea certainly would be
that you're taking a calculated risk to
go and potentially to get beat up a
little bit in the West in year one and
when you're 33 years old that seems like
a crazy concept to leave the east after
all these years and so when
Finals appearances and you know not only
go to the west but go there without the
kind of help you need but you know I
don't know maybe he if you can't get the
help right now he looks at it and next
summer brings with it the fact that
wherever Kauai goes he'll be a free
agent you know there's other names Jimmy
Butler klay Thompson guys like that guys
who were gonna be available so yeah I do
get the sense that his interest in LA is
great enough to the point where that
kind of a scenario would at least be
contemplated if you're trying to trade
for Paul George I'm assuming you're
gonna have to do a sign-and-trade with
Paul George and/or Kawhi Leonard correct
not so much at all no I mean Paul you
know is its free to go so I mean in
Kauai
but money if he signs it like he could
signed for the max with Oklahoma City
and then it's as if I'm Oklahoma City
and I give you the max but I won't sign
and trade and then he's gonna want the
max money as well not many guys walk
away from that right no you're right I
mean the financial incentive for sure is
pushing on the other way okay so if
you're gonna trade there's only so much
you have to trade is LeBron going to be
a sign-and-trade know the brahman so
he's got till Thursday the 29th whatever
that is to decide on his player option
the sign and trade if he was gonna go
that route it would be like Chris Paul
last year where we would hear about this
before July 1 meaning he would say I'm
gonna opt in to that player option and
then I'm gonna force you to move me
somewhere else so that that's the avenue
for him could you see LeBron and Lonzo
ball coexistent I could yeah no you know
I had this moment I'm certainly not a
lot of this front but last summer summer
league action between the Lakers and the
Sixers and you probably remember when
LeBron showed up to the game I had the
best seat in the house at the Thomas and
Mack scanner I was in the press row and
LeBron sat in front of myself and Howard
back from Bleacher Report and we ended
up chatting with him a little bit but in
that moment it was it was Ben Simmons
was there
Lonzo ball was on the floor LeBron was
sending all these different mixed
signals but
he was tweeting about their instagraming
about lonzo's shoes you know and so that
was when we started connecting those
dots between Alonso and LeBron I mean I
could see them coexisting Basketball
Wives I think the the off court
situation with levar you know is
something we've debated for a long time
I think LaVon would have no problem
handling that and making that
relationship work so you know I could
see that yeah it's tough we're still
amazed that Lonzo ball can't shoot
free-throws I calculate your point guard
not be it at least a 75% free-throw
shooter 100% that's where that's where
X's and O's wise it gets so tricky
because right now this iteration of
Lonzo needs the ball in his hands and
he's gonna do anything good on the floor
you got to be touching that thing
and you know we all know how much LeBron
wants the ball so he would have to
evolve and evolve quickly and and you
know put his nose to the grindstone and
become the kind of player the Lakers
thought he was when they take them
number two but you know he's he is a guy
that even for all the stuff around the
edges
I think continues to have a lot of
promise you know I think he would work
you know you you would need some
shooters and he would need guys who put
that ball in the bucket and need some
guys who defend but I think it could
download you know got a lot be good what
do you think happens first day in free
agency well today is an interesting and
we're just around here but you know the
today's the first little bit of clarity
in it Ramona Shelburne and ESPN had
reported this morning that LeBrons not
going to want any of the circus-like
presentations this time around that you
know have taken place in the past you
know I've talked to some lebrons folks
and that is the case it's it's the
interesting thing though is it doesn't
mean that he's not going to take phone
calls with these teams it doesn't mean
that he might not ultimately meet with
teams it's just not going to have you
know that circus element to it that
certainly was there in 2010 so I don't
know what that means he's taking a
business approach and so all eyes are
gonna be on the Brawn on day one and
what he is doing let's assume that he
just does not pick up that player
officer for next season he's an
unrestricted free agent from there it's
your classic case of
each Domino has to fall and but with I
think a twist this year because really
LeBron is gonna be reacting to what some
of those guys we already talked about
are doing and those dominoes in
whichever directions that are leaning
they're looking like they're gonna fall
is I think in a dictate partly what he
does I don't know if you thought about
this Sam and I overthink things all the
time or read into it but I went when I
saw the Cavs take college Sexton I
immediately thought well maybe he's a
chip to trade to Charlotte to get Kemba
Walker if they're trying to get Kimble
Walker out of Charlotte sure I don't
know if there are any other deals that
you saw that may lead to other deals but
that was one that kind of stood out to
me okay yeah I mean that makes logical
sense right and the canvas stuff you
know along I mean the Cavs are well
aware they've got to make some noise
here really quick if they wanted to up
the odds of LeBron not leaving town and
I think honestly if they did something
like that they'd be in the catbird seat
because and you know what I don't know
exactly where LeBron is at when it comes
to his view and dynamic with Dan Gilbert
and whether or not that's a non-starter
in terms of him returning but but it
does seem that his folks are putting out
the message that Cleveland is still not
only in the game but but on the
shortlist and you know I move like that
would get you in a much better position
you know the one I wrote about the other
day through they you know they inquire
about Kawhi Leonard I you know tracks in
there because the Spurs aren't helping
anybody yet but the Cavs are not any
different than any of these other teams
trying to impress LeBron by adding
Talent making it more compelling the
section thing if you're Charlotte I mean
that gives you a guy to to turn the page
with with the Miss Kupchak you know
obviously leaves are way out there so no
I can buy that I guess the Kawhi Leonard
situation I'll leave you with this of
when does it become untenable if San
Antonio is forced to trade him that he
doesn't want to stay there what what is
the time frame for that when they'll
know it and be willing to try to put
together a deal well I think the under
top knot in reported aspect of this that
even if they mend fences and they get it
to a place that doesn't have acrimony
relationship-wise they can offer them
five-year 215 million dollar extension
on July 1st there have been things
written and reported in the media that
would seem to indicate that not
surprisingly they're very very hesitant
or maybe just completely unwilling time
for that extension so timeline wise if
July 1 comes and goes and they don't
offer that extension the wise people
aren't gonna put this thing into
hyperdrive and say it's time for us to
go we have no interest in simply playing
out this contract and letting you
control his future because I'm wondering
how long Popovich is going to be there
like does that factor in at all with
Kawhi Leonard I mean I would assume so I
think if factors in a little bit with
with all these top-tier players you know
he's got the team ulis and
responsibilities you know that 2020
seems to be you know kind of the the
protected or speculated upon time issue
where we wonder if he's gonna keep going
yeah you know Mike singer of the Senate
was a great job it might got a good
telescope a painting the picture that
you know that people wondered after
Pop's wife passed away so tragically if
he was gonna walk away this where does
he need any of this nonsense so he's
back for next year but I think certainly
it's kind of a year-by-year proposition
at this point sim great stuff have fun
this week and we appreciate your time
thank you Sam amick but he's been
mispronouncing his name so it's Sam
ammok USA Today NBA insider for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
you